veamos supongamos que la compañía a bs d
no es de tu preferencia y estás
convencido de que sus acciones van a
irse a la baja entonces en esta
situación es cuando puedes tener una
venta corta una venta corta de esta
acción que en un nivel muy elevado es
apostar a que esta acción se irá a la
baja y la forma de hacer esto
mecánicamente es cuando le pides
prestada una acción a alguien más y
pides puesta esta acción a alguien más
que la tenga ojo y de manera inmediata
vendes esta acción al precio actual de
esa acción veamos un ejemplo va a quedar
mucho más claro en esta situación tú
vendes esta acción al precio de 50 pesos
ese es su precio en el momento en el que
la vendes y ahora vas a esperar que el
peso de la acción vaya a la baja así que
en esta primera instancia en esta
primera situación vamos a suponer que en
efecto el precio de la acción va a la
baja
es una situación hipotética puede que no
sea así y bueno así que la méndez puede
ser que pidas prestado y las vendas por
50 pesos en eso quedamos y en eso la
acción baja de precio 10 más vamos a
suponer que baja hasta 20 pesos y más
aún tú piensas que es todo lo que va a
bajar es decir tienes una corazonada de
que no va a bajar más el precio de la
acción y en ese momento decides comprar
la de nuevo que la acción regrese a ti
entonces compras de nuevo esta acción
pero esta vez por el precio de 20 pesos
y ojo si no estudia la acción la
regresas a su propietario porque ahora
que ya regresaste esta acción tu has
conseguido lo que quieres ya no es
necesario quedarse la más tiempo tú la
vendes después la compras y ya cuáles
obtuviste 30 pesos eso suponiendo que el
precio de la acción se estabiliza de
nuevo en 20 pesos casi siempre para
vender algo necesitas comprar ese algo y
bueno regresando las cuentas tú vendiste
acción a 50 pesos y la compraste de
vuelta a 20 pesos ganando así 30 pesos
por acción y bueno todo esto gracias a
tu corazonada así
en esta situación con la venta rápida
haciendo la maniobra de vender y de
comprar rápidamente logrando conseguir y
hacer 30 pesos ahora bien es solamente
que en este escenario es el escenario
positivo el escenario soñado porque hay
que tener cuidado
la corazonada puede fallar no todo en la
vida es miel sobre ojuelas si tu
corazonada es incorrecta y supongamos
que el precio no baja sino que más bien
sube y sube hasta 80 pesos justo aquí
entonces te asustas y dices oh dios mío
tengo que comprar esta acción de vuelta
pues vamos a suponer que la petista
prestada y que la tienes que regresar
pero esta vez va a valer 80 pesos subió
de precio y entonces te preguntas qué
pasa si no la compro ahora sigue
subiendo yo la tengo que regresar y
entonces voy a perder una cantidad de
dinero infinito terminará en la
bancarrota
así que decides parar ahí pues mueres
enviado por una situación que parece ser
incierta y entonces dices ok la
compraría de vuelta 80 pesos y bueno en
esta terrorífica situación lo que pasó
es que tú perdiste 30 pesos 30 pesos
negativos realmente estas ventas cortas
son todo un riesgo
no puedes asegurar que el precio de la
acción siga creciendo infinitamente es
incierto imagínate que de repente el
precio de la acción suba 800 pesos o tal
vez de forma loca suba ocho mil pesos o
lo que sea para tu desgracia el problema
de pedirle prestada es que tuve en
chiste esa acción en 50 pesos así que en
efecto es un gran riesgo pero también si
tienes jugadas con las sonadas es un
riesgo que puede darte dinero si el
precio de la acción baja